harry and meghan markle's relationship
with the royal family this is crazy
the tensions are escalating over the
timing of the oprah tell-all
i am here for it there's a lot that's
been lost already i don't know how they
could expect
that after all of this time we would
still just be silent
if there is an active role that the firm
is playing
in perpetuating falsehoods about us
a sure sign the royal gloves are off
megan's use of the phrase
the firm there is an active role that
the firm is playing
it has a negative connotation suggesting
the royals are more worried about
business
than family we're not a family we're a
firm
it also hints at megan's annoyance with
core royal family members
and senior staffers megan's apparent dig
is just the latest shot fired in a
brutal war of words
the new 30-second teaser clip featuring
megan was released seven hours after a
palace statement
that targeted her buckingham palace said
it would launch an
investigation into allegations megan
bullied former members of her staff
something she called a calculated smear
campaign
clearly this interview has set alarm
bells ringing at the palace
and there's drama surrounding harry and
his grandparents
a source tells e.t the timing of the
oprah interview
has complicated matters with them we've
seen them a few times they've seen
archie running around
we're told some members of the family
encouraged harry to return if possible
to see phillip although another source
denies this
the duke of edinburgh turns 100 this
year and underwent a successful heart
procedure
yesterday i think this interview does
have the potential to cause real damage
between harry and the rest of the royal
family
this is going to blow open that rift all
over again
you